last box o loot boxes is back as a
controversy you may remember last year
with csgo lotto there was a two
youtubers that owned the company of loot
crate gambling company but loot crate is
back again on everyone's radar thanks to
EA Thank You EA now loot crate just
seems to be everywhere these days you
know I try and buy a sandwich
would you like to loot crate the
ingredients and see what you could get
you could get the legendary mozzarella
or perhaps when I go to the public
restroom would you like to loot crate
the toilet paper you can get a legendary
drop where a man will wipe your anus for
you sir it's it's impeccable or you
could just win toilet paper
we need more loot crate's III keep
telling everyone there's not enough loot
crate's
csgo has it overwatch has it even pub G
has it so there really should be no
surprise that the latest Star Wars
Battlefront 2 has loot crate in its loot
boxes whatever they called I am just
thrilled I can't wait to open all those
boxes on camera and have an epic
freakout over what's inside oh my god a
virtual skin for Mike Neath that is
definitely exciting maybe I'm not the
right person to criticize loot boxes cuz
I personally have zero interest in them
I find them extremely repetitive boring
I don't see the appeal in virtual
clothing ok it just seems like something
not that appealing but EA was sitting
down at a meeting doing their quarterly
finances and trying to brainstorm ideas
on how
to get more money how can we squeeze
more money out of our customer how about
we make our own distribution platform
cutting off steam and making the general
experience of accessing our games a
giant cheoreom genius that's genius
but not evil enough how can we make
people pay $69.99 instead of $54.99 well
we'll give them the elite
edition those idiots will love it but
not evil enough what about day 1 dlc not
evil enough what about a season pass not
evil enough
ok I got it once they spent 69 99 pounds
they'll spend even more on loot boxes
excellent now look boxes is nothing new
and really all this controversy that
started run EA and SAR Wars someone on
reddit that was testing out the game
figured out that since their rewards are
no longer based on your skill in the
game let's say if you perform really
well in the game it's hardly affected
it's morally based on how much time you
play the game so if you want to play as
Darth Vader in the new Star Wars game
you have to unlock him as a hero
and to unlock heroes you do so by
purchasing loot boxes or you can earn
them through through playing the game
seems fair enough
you know you get two options but someone
did some math and calculated that it
took it'll take you 40 hours of gameplay
to unlock one hero and that is cutting
out all the loading screens all the time
between matches and the fact that you
can't buy any other loot crate's
in the meantime you really have to focus
40 hours specifically for that change to
get that hero drop or you know you can
just pay 20 bucks
I mean it's genius you know you have
people spend this amount of money
already why not make them spend more
needless to say people weren't too happy
about this the post went viral on reddit
EA then made a response which you know
was probably the most well crafted
well-thought-out response of all time
which is why it got 20,000 minus points
the most disliked
post ever on reddit congratulations
let's see what it says our goal involves
creating a compelling progression path
for all our players by spending 40 hours
there's a lot of content at lunch with
even more coming when you pay 64 pounds
you get a lot of things not all of
things but a lot of things the intent is
to pride players with a sense of pride
and accomplishments for unlocking
different heroes or you can just pay us
20 dollars here's a here's why my
opinion just goes out the toilet I agree
that loot boxes are terrible
it's a scummy way of practice but if you
hate them so much just don't buy them
just don't buy them they exist for a
reason they exist because people are
dumb enough to buy them now I understand
that the concept is that whales pretty
much as they're called people just spend
an over load amount of money on the game
and that's how they make most of their
profit because they really squeeze that
an insane amount out of certain
consumers it's not like everyone is
buying the loot crate's is actually
probably a tenth of players that are
actually buying them but that's enough
to justify them existing and it just
overall ruin the experience for everyone
playing the game it's not like EA has
the best track record I don't see how
anyone is surprised by this do you do
you not remember how many how many dlcs
therefore simps Sims living large Sims
house party Sims hot date these were all
treated as individual games an expansion
packs and they've been doing this for
years and it's not like the pole
practice of gambling isn't or buying
something and not getting quite what you
want is has never existed before we
practically grow up with it as kids and
maybe it's cuz I'm not the biggest star
wars fan ever
but basically EA is holding holding the
franchise hasta is pretty much oh man
we're really sorry you do like our loot
crate system guys we just wanted to game
to be fair for everyone you know
maybe here players catch up if they can
find by buying a couple of loot crate's
hmm if you weren't we could give you
names of some other companies that are
making Star Wars games oh wait we're the
only weapons aren't we mm I guess you'll
have to buy some loot crate's
now despite what your opinion on the
topic is the memes the memes are very
fresh okay they're very nice
eh new proposed handheld console I
really I really appreciate this one we
here at EA honestly do not remember
making battlefront a pay2win game the
story has encouraged us to address other
things in about our company we have
loved and had romantic encounters with
men throughout our life and we choose
now to live as a game man how brave
brave Electronic Arts now a lot of
people got fired back around a whole
controversy as well because there was
this guy named Big Sean claiming to work
for EA saying that he got seven death
threats and over 1,600 individual
personal attacks now I don't know how
you calculate that like you can keep up
with all of them and I don't mean to
sound insensitive or anything but if I
made a big deal out of any time I got a
death threat on the internet I wouldn't
have time to make videos it's not the
death threats on the internet don't mean
anything but that's another topic now a
lot of game magazines took it upon
themselves to use this as an opportunity
to point out how awful gamers are for
criticizing the poor game devs when it
turns out there's no confirmation that
he actually works for EA most likely he
doesn't work for you but at the same
time who really [ __ ] cares at the end
of the day it's Disney and EA two large
companies they're gonna squeeze out as
much money as they can what you can do
as a consumer is to not buy into it
don't be that brainless Star Wars fan
boy that has to buy all of them just
don't buy this one stop buying blue
crates refund your games and stop crying
seriously I found that there's a
petition so that the ESRB award declare
loot boxes as gambling which I hundred
percent agree with it is a form of
gambling
and he should be rated as such it blows
my mind that people are concerned Disney
we're somehow trying to squeeze money
out of people like that's never done
before by indie games you have people
working passionately on their own
projects support them instead we have so
many options right now as a gamer this
year was incredible we got so many great
releases support them instead it's rich
it's really not that complicated anyway
thank you for watching this video
do you agree or disagree leave a comment
down below leave a like if you enjoyed
watching one like you could unlock my
new loot box system where in every video
I'm announcing your loot box where you
could win another video while finishing
up this video EA star wars made another
statement three statements about this
thing I sure hope they get it right this
time this was never our intention sorry
we didn't get this right we hear you
loud and clear so we're turning off all
in-game purchases that is fantastic they
listened to consider community and they
responded wait a minute the ability to
purchase crystals in-game will become
available at later date so basically
you're just trying to save the launch
and you're gonna add microtransactions
anyway congratulations to everyone I
know people are gonna be pissed about
this but at the same time they have a
budget to recoup and they had a
financial plan in this game they're
gonna have to do it regardless they
can't just give out it's not a charity
I feel like this everyone loses Congrats